there is an old saying nothing better
than a friend unless it is a friend with
chocolate and luckily we have both today
joining me from love chocolate dessert
shop is owner alicia cerna welcome hi
thank you for having me today new shop
and i'm looking and you literally have
everything that is chocolate tell me a
little bit about this new business that
you just started yeah so i've been in
business for over a year and a half now
okay originally located in the bay area
but we just moved out here three weeks
ago so now we're trying to open up shop
here in las vegas we offer things from
custom cakes chocolate covered
strawberries cupcakes pretty much
anything like you said that's chocolate
we can make it oh i love it well let's
um you're going to teach me how to make
something really cool that i actually
love we're going to go ahead and dip
some chocolate covered strawberries here
now these look really intricate is it
difficult
i mean it's not just dip is it the yours
are so pretty the ones i make are just
all ooh
so we're going to go ahead and try to
make those the best that we can so these
strawberries are already pre-washed and
ready to go so okay here's a strawberry
for you and then we're going to go ahead
and just stick toothpicks inside
just right in the stem in the stem yeah
okay all right here now
this is if people want to order how do
they place an order here so you can go
to my instagram um which is love
chocolate dessert shop we also have a
website which is love chocolate dessert
shop.com you can go ahead and place
orders there so go ahead and just move
this spatula out of the way okay and you
just want to dip it right in
just go for it yes and turn rotate it
all around so you want to make sure the
whole strawberry is dipped in chocolate
there you go and then lift up lift up
and shake it off all the you see how the
chocolate is running yes and you can
wipe it down here okay
and then you just place it there and and
then you you decorate it so beautifully
what do you put on them i brought some
things so this is like a sprayable
glitter so you can go ahead and just
spray this is for jelly and i'm gonna
put some sprayable glitter on there
normally we'll wait till the chocolate
is um dry but since it's a short segment
we're going to go ahead and just go
ahead and put on the decorations now
there's a few decorations you can put on
here's a little diploma a grad cap
how far in advance if people want to
place an order do they need to
do that for treats i say about two weeks
and for cakes anywhere from two to three
weeks as well what what is so special
about your shop that just sets it apart
from everything else i would say that
everything we do is custom our logo our
slogan is that trees that look too good
to eat oh and they do if you take a look
at some of these treats i mean
please tell me that these are chocolate
covered oreos as they are i love that so
many great things custom cakes cupcakes
chocolate covered strawberries and
basically if you think of it i bet you
can put a great spin on it if you have
an idea we'll go ahead and recreate it
for you i love it that's edible and one
more time the website in case people
want to place an order love chocolate
dessert shop.com or you can find her on
instagram thank you thank you
there's more las vegas